This wonderful app developer
out of the United Arab Emerits,
the company is called Megabit.
And he creates games, basically.
But he started out
making his first game,
in his first year, he made like $2,000.
And he is living at
home with his parents.
And his parents are like why
are you doing this as a business?
This is crazy.
I can't believe you're spending all
your time building these apps, right?
You should go back to school,
become an engineer.
You know, maybe, become a doctor.
You know, whatever it may be.
And he was like no, no, no.
I really love doing this.
So he started doing it more.
And then the second year,
he made probably like $14,000 and
he was like well, at least,
I'm going up, right?
And kept building, and
kept moving, chugging along.
And a year later,
he made close to $250,000.
And his parents were like, stay in it.
Do everything you can to stay.
[LAUGH] Now his brother's
helping him out.
And he is looking to hopefully,
create close to $1 million this year.
So it just shows you monetization,
even though you start very small.
There's no guidebook
to what's successful.
Really understanding your users, and
then trying to build off of that.
So you can grow your business.